y
[Música]
ciudadanos afganos se tumbaron las
calles para protestar en contra del
dominio del grupo talibán hoy cuando se
conmemoran los 102 años de independencia
del país del imperio británico se han
reportado varios muertos y heridos por
disparos de los talibanes cuyo accionar
se aleja las recientes promesas de paz
hay preocupación por parte de la
comunidad internacional
en el día el número de muertos asciende
en medio de dificultades para la entrega
de ayuda humanitaria después del
terremoto de magnitud 7,2 que sacudió el
país el pasado 14 de agosto en el asedio
de las pandillas y una crisis política y
de gobernabilidad en la nación caribeña
los damnificados denuncian sentirse
desamparados y sin ayuda del estado
y el departamento del tesoro de eeuu
anunció más sanciones contra altos
funcionarios del gobierno cubano
señalando los como responsables de la
represión durante las protestas de julio
en la isla entretanto amnistía
internacional nombró a seis presos de
conciencia y pidió su inmediata
liberación
volvemos con más información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí estas
veinticuatro mi nombre es liliana
valencia organista cerebro su día de la
independencia 102 años desde el fin del
dominio británico una oportunidad que
los civiles han aprovechado para
protestar contra el talibán usando el
gran símbolo del momento la bandera
tricolor protestas que según reportes se
vieron reprimidas con disparos del grupo
talibán estamos este informe de ellos
muñoz
contra el talibán la bandera se ha
convertido en el símbolo de resistencia
entre los afganos especialmente este
jueves cuando se conmemora la
independencia del control británico de
1919 con protestas por todo el país
los talibanes deberían venir y
arrodillarse ante nosotros nunca nos
arrodillaremos ante ellos una realidad
muy diferente a la que viven desde el
talibán los extremistas continúan
patrullando kabul la capital se hacen
ver ante la población local
el mercado está muy concurrido la gente
está muy feliz una gran cantidad de
personas y residentes de kabul ya no nos
tienen miedo gracias a dios esta
tranquilidad vista del aeropuerto de
kabul donde han muerto más de una decena
de personas por disparos por estampida
sí por caídas desde aviones la
evacuación continúa liderada por eeuu
que desde que comenzaron las operaciones
de evacuación el 14 de agosto hemos
trasladado por aire a aproximadamente 7
mil evacuados y back y wish pero más
allá de eeuu las imágenes del éxodo se
repiten por distintos aeropuertos del
mundo
esto es roma y esto dubai pero no es
suficiente cientos de afganos continúan
agolpados
a esto se suma la desesperación de la
gente y la sensación de que se acaba el
tiempo para salir según el ministro de
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov la
resistencia al talibán controla el valle
de panshir encabezados por el
vicepresidente depuesto and rulas saleh
ahmad masood hijo de un mítico
comandante asesinado por al qaeda en
el talibán controla de facto el país del
pasado domingo cuando entraron en kabul
hasta el momento la comunidad
internacional no reconoce su gobierno y
aspira a que el grupo insurgente cumpla
sus promesas de respeto a los derechos
humanos principalmente los de las
mujeres el secretario general de la onu
dijo que dicha ambición de
reconocimiento puede ser usada para
presionar por otros objetivos en el país
veamos este informe de rosa pérez más d
controlan gran parte de la población del
territorio y de las fronteras pero de
momento la autoridad talibán no tiene
reconocimiento internacional
algo que el secretario general de
naciones unidas pide aprovechar a cambio
de garantías de respeto de los derechos
humanos chips very important es muy
importante que todos los miembros del
consejo de seguridad pero en general de
la comunidad internacional estén unidos
para usar el único punto de presión que
existe el interés del talibán a alcanzar
legitimidad y reconocimiento de bank for
los sistemas y forrest jones el talibán
es la única autoridad de facto en
afganistán y las grandes potencias de
forma pragmática lo tratan como tal
china preparaba desde hacía tiempo el
escenario post retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses y la interesa una
relación de buena vecindad con las
autoridades del talibán
[__] ming lado a pesar de que la
situación en afganistán todavía no esté
clara consideramos que el grupo talibán
no repetirá el pasado el talibán tiene
las cosas más claras y es más racional
que la última vez que estuvo en el poder
sí sí sí
rusia afirmó que mantiene su voluntad de
diálogo con todos los actores afganos y
turquía que ayudará al nuevo gobierno en
el terreno internacional en una
entrevista con la cadena ibis y news joe
biden tampoco cerró la puerta al
reconocimiento de un gobierno talibán ha
cambiado y
creo que están en una especie de crisis
existencial sobre si quieren ser
reconocidos por la comunidad
internacional como un gobierno legítimo
y no quiero marcarme no estoy seguro de
que eso quieran en medio de una
creciente represión en afganistán la
comunidad internacional espera que el
talibán cumpla sus promesas de respeto
de los derechos humanos para un eventual
reconocimiento internacional como
gobierno legítimo aunque sean cuales
sean sus acciones nadie podrá negar su
poder tras 20 años de una guerra que
termina como empezó con el talibán
dominando kabul
las autoridades en haití reportaron 2000
189 muertos y 12.000 200 heridos tras el
terremoto el sábado 14 de agosto
mientras sigue subiendo la cita de
víctimas fatales las organizaciones
humanitarias tratan de hacerles llegar
ayuda humanitaria a los damnificados sin
embargo existe un gran escepticismo por
los problemas de gobernabilidad que
afronta el país además del control
territorial de las pandillas
pero crece el número de muertos en haití
pero desciende la atención mediática e
internacional así lo justificó para
france24 william pierde listón doctor en
ciencia política y administración
pública y no solamente lo que está
pasando en afganistán también en la
situación de la pandilla también muchos
países tienen mucho problema para para
resolver a centenares de personas hacen
fila en un campamento de campesino en
los cayos cada familia puede recibir 50
kilos del programa mundial de alimentos
de la onu suficientes para un mes las
ayudas aunque llegan se retrasan entre
las causas por un lado los
deslizamientos de los últimos días tras
fuertes lluvias pero también por la
amenaza de las pandillas que en los
últimos años han desplazado a las
organizaciones es otra cosa cambia en la
inseguridad hace que muchos de estos
personales de los ongs que estaban en el
país ya no están como que la comunidad
internacional es muy exigente de
encontrar una persona de cuánto para
entregar esos fondos aunque a principios
de semana las pandillas habían dado una
3 para atender a las víctimas del
terremoto del sábado dos médicos fueron
secuestrados en puerto príncipe un
problema que viene de largo
la garantía el gobierno los está dando
el problema es que antes del terremoto
había parte esta parte particularmente
al gobierno no tenía control sobre este
esta parte del país haití es el país más
pobre de américa el 7 de julio su
presidente joven él fue asesinado por
mercenarios un estado fallido que desde
el terremoto de 2010 del cual dejó más
de 200.000 fallecidos sigue sin
encontrar el rumbo inmerso en una nueva
tragedia
hablamos ahora de cuba porque el
departamento del tesoro de eeuu anunció
nuevas sanciones contra tres
funcionarios del gobierno comunista por
considerar que están involucrados en
actos de represión durante las
manifestaciones sociales del mes de
julio entre los recientes sancionados se
encuentra roberto negra y andrés
laureano gonzález del ministerio de la
fuerza armada revolucionaria y hablar 2
jiménez del ministerio del interior
las sanciones bajo la llamada ley global
magnitski prohíben de transacciones a
través del sistema financiero de eeuu
así como el congelamiento de activos en
ese país entretanto amnistía
internacional sostuvo que el gobierno
cubano criminaliza la protesta pacífica
encarcela y maltrata a personas cubanas
sólo por expresar su opinión y nombró a
seis de los detenidos como presos de
conciencia pidiendo su inmediata
liberación
hemos nombrado a seis personas como
presas de conciencia en un gesto
simbólico hacia los muchos cientos más
que seguramente merecen esta designación
y pedimos libertad inmediata e
incondicional el cuadro de violaciones
de derechos humanos que hemos
documentado en las últimas semanas
apunta a una política de represión
reforzada para recuperar el control y
restablecer una cultura de miedo que se
tan valió el 11 de julio en noticias del
coi 19 la escasez de vacunas de sputnik
ve de fabricación rusa en venezuela ha
complicado más el plan de vacunación que
ya era un proceso lento y desorganizado
las autoridades de venezuela no se han
referido a las fallas en el suministro
de las dosis necesarias para completar
las pautas de vacunación en la población
está por expulsar el caracas bicol
kolster nos amplía
carmen cara de 77 años no ha podido
completar su inmunización contra kobe 19
por la escasez de la segunda dosis de la
russa después ni venezuela le
correspondía la segunda inyección en
junio fuego
nos dijeron que el siguiente día mi hija
por el siguiente día le dijeron que
no estaban poniendo la vacuna carmen que
sufre de diabetes y es hipertensa evita
salir de casa no puedo salir tengo mi
casa en el pueblo y no puedo ir me he
podido y tengo un año convocarme muchos
otros que fueron vacunados con la
primera dosis de la sputnik hoy no
tienen la certeza de cuándo podrán
finalizar su inmunización dado los
retrasos en la entrega
afuera de un centro de vacunación
repleto de personas está anillo adrianza
276 informaron que no había porque una
rusa sino las chinas y no sabíamos para
ponerle la celina
quienes fueron inoculados con la primera
dosis de la russa visitan constantemente
su centro de vacunación en busca de
información casi siempre en vano la
mayoría de estos la única vacuna
disponible la china sino farm sin que
hasta ahora se haya recomendado su
combinación
manuel enríquez higuera presidente de la
sociedad venezolana de infectología
define el plan de vacunación del
gobierno de venezuela como político y no
técnico están vacunando sin ningún tipo
de estructura sin ningún tipo
organización sin planificación con
desorden grandes colas grandes
información las personas ni siquiera
saben que van a recibir donde lo van a
recibir
las maduro de acuerdo con rusia la
entrega de 10 millones de unidades pero
sólo se conoce que llegaron al país
1.430.000 y a medida que la escasez de
vacunas se hace más evidente en los
centros de vacunación es mucho más
difícil poder ingresar a ellos
custodiados por militares y policías
nicole kolster france24 caracas hablamos
ahora de líbano porque mientras continúa
la escasez de gasolina y otros
suministros básicos el líder de
hezbollah la facción más poderosa del
país anunció un envío de combustible
desde irán sin embargo acciones como
ésta van en contra de las sanciones
impuestas por estados unidos a la nación
islámica y pueden generar nuevas
dificultades para el líbano que pasa por
la peor de sus crisis a nivel económico
y social
los seguidores de hezbollah celebran que
su líder hassan nasrallah tomó las
riendas de la situación anunció que un
buque iraní con combustible zarpará
hacia líbano y advirtió a sus enemigos
que no intenten intervenir hasta final
la embarcación proveniente de iranshahr
para en las próximas horas azul del
américa los estadounidenses e israelíes
les digo es territorio libanés
nasralá aseguró que el cargamento será
el primero de muchos sin embargo la
entrega violan las sanciones que estados
unidos impone a irán y los opositores a
hezbollah alertan que esto puede
implicar sanciones para líbano un país
en bancarrota
[Aplausos]
el estado libanés no puede permitirse
importaciones en sectores clave y
después de que el banco central cortará
los subsidios al combustible la escasez
de luz ha empeorado y ha desencadenado
el cierre de oficinas hospitales y
negocios
no tengo gas para el horno no tengo
electricidad para hacer pan en la sartén
he tenido que tirar todas mis
provisiones que debo hacer horas después
del anuncio de nasralá la presidencia
libanesa aseguró que eeuu suministrará
electricidad es de jordania y
combustible desde egipto
organizaciones internacionales han
prometido cientos de millones de euros
en ayuda a líbano si sus políticos
logran formar un gabinete estable que
reforme el país algo que todavía tiene
que suceder
finalizamos con noticias del continente
africano porque la cifra de muertos en
burkina faso subió a 80 entre civiles y
militares hacia el ataque perpetrado el
miércoles por milicias islamistas que
llenaron un convoy civil escoltado por
la policía militar cerca de la ciudad de
harbín da se trata del más reciente de
una serie de ataques en la región de
sahel en áfrica occidental durante el
último mes 59 civiles es milicias
gubernamentales
o progubernamentales y 15 policías
militares murieron y también así lo
confirmaron el gobierno y el ejército
altos mandos militares visitaron a los
sobrevivientes del hospital central de
la región inicialmente la cifra de
muertos se habría calculado en 47
para realizar también damos un repaso a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
donde usted puede encontrar información
en cuatro idiomas tenemos en este
momento la noticia principal en la
crisis por los incendios forestales en
california
escala en medio de vientos extremos está
y además información acerca de la crisis
a por el más reciente terremoto en la
isla y también la entrega del hombre que
causó pánico en las inmediaciones del
congreso en washington al afirmar que
tenía explosivos dentro de su vehículo
también por supuesto información en
venezuela donde el presidente nicolás
maduro cambio de manera sorpresiva al
canciller del país y no estoy mucho más
podrán encontrarlo en 324 puntocom
no vemos más adelante con más
información
soy xavier colás